number 12
[Music]
[Music]
ensure this is the North Star
[Music]
[Applause]
if you can manage across the fighting
noises and looks at Bruce Lee the
invincibility of Chuck Norris the body
of Sylvester Stallone the martial arts
of an ancient Chi master and the sperm
of Hercules then you get the invincible
indestructible untouchable deadly
skillful all-powerful Almighty Kenshiro
course ma'am one of the most iconic
characters to ever come out of the shown
in genre can sure is one badass must be
due to have his names and looks known
all around the anime community in fact
prior to make this list I hadn't even
seen a single episode of fist and off
stuff and yet I knew that Kenshiro would
be on his list based entirely on his
reputation and after watching a few
episodes he definitely does not
disappoint
yes Ken Shearer and the character
preceding him are two characters a foot
on the Swiss based on their infamous
reputation in anime fandom
and who both inherently are using with
big Mally muscles and pure hardcore
epicness a lot roebuck interior burst at
the end of the 20th century the earth
has been scarred with nuclear warfare
leaving most of the surface as a barren
wasteland in a time when the waters
apparently ruled by palmtop sex pistol
fans can share our travels around
protecting the weak and innocent against
these murderous gangs he's trained in
deadly art and hopped ocean camera an
ancient martial art used for
assassination that allow you to have
absolute mastery of an opponent's body
by just pushing some pressure points
which when hit and we're certainly
ensures the opponent's death in a matter
of seconds sprouting his famous
catchphrase which is normally used to
signal to countdown to a site of a body
blowing yourself up from the inside out
yes this guy will blow your mind
awesome pun intended when a huge body of
his he bares seven squads that form the
pattern of the North Star which he going
graves into him after losing his lost
love Julia to a bitter rival he also
bears a striking resemblance Bruce Lee
if Bruce Lee had been jacked up steroids
from birth and has added
perhaps states their wines up with anime
characters from the seventies and
eighties with some either had big
flareon was greater than his facial
features so after hearing what this two
already need to explain this guy's
placement on the list not only is he the
embodiment of every testosterone based
tribe you associate with the word Chuck
Norris but he can also make your head
explode with the use of his [ __ ]
fingers what more do you want though
while certainly his most badass feat his
lady heads explode he could be more than
just that with his martial arts though
this made me question the number of
bloody acupuncture points are on the
heating body I mean there are parenting
points that can make you speak this true
for against your will someone instantly
closed up fatal wounds and some will
make your heart explode while taking
exactly and only exactly five steps wait
hold on a sec not to mention how skilled
yes we have accurately pushed tiny fresh
points during combat while having arms a
size of fat babies complete with sausage
fingers then again I've gathered in a
series easy with pure manly testosterone
everyone's been taking way too many
steroids in his and maces a1 feel like a
[ __ ] brick [ __ ] but of course
his most iconic movies his thousand
bunches or as I like to call it sir you
just got FD me a attack this move is
basically a flurry of punches against
the opponent which when initiated causes
his shirt and his synth great off his
body in the most manliest fashion while
still keep his trousers in very nice
condition but the most memorable thing
about this move of course is the attacks
on teammates reminiscent of Bruce Lee's
fighting noises it is so epic secures
his invincibility when using this attack
since when he's using this move nobody
and I mean nobody touches him
fortunately for me he just seems like a
one-trick pony
even if blowing up someone's head is a
pretty cool power compared to the number
of power of the night's guards list has
then what it seemed by too much I may be
wrong with this since I'm not very far
three fits in an off style yet but [ __ ]
I'm not gonna watch through hundreds of
episodes just so this guy can get placed
a little higher does this however his
epicness certainly does live up to
reputation and if anyone is stupid
enough to go against this guy then don't
because if you do then you are already
dead number 11
[Music]
Dio Brando from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
the art of having muscle was big enough
to crush a small elephant to death for
something I originally thought any
Dragon Ball Z I'd pull it off though as
it turned out some characters can make
even go to look like a baby panda in
terms of muscle size as we've just seen
from fyssas and off site also with
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure when you come
from a man way where your characters
have enough steroid pumped in serum that
makes their chests so oversized it looks
like you're squeezing their massive
breast implants under your tank top you
have to do something else to stand up in
the crowd so enter Dio Brando originally
the brother to his archenemy Jonathan
Joestar do became a vampire ultimately
got his head chopped off why Joestar who
sacrifices like to sing both his body
nto severed head into the Atlantic Ocean
over time tre attaches his head to
joestars body apparently by tentacle
raping the body to death and from there
he gains psychic powers where he plans
his revenge against the Joestar line to
suck the blood of all the members in the
Joestar family further feeding the
compatibility from his head to his body
and increasing control his newfound
powers now Theo is on his list mostly
due to the same big manly muscly reasons
that can sure is but says from just
above Ken sure it's just how [ __ ]
hardcore the sky is in comparison I mean
if he just ignore looks and that in
itself is oddity he has enough
superpowers like the Justice League
looked like a bunch of [ __ ] if we're
just talking anime powers well he's a
vampire he could body snatch instant
regeneration brainwashing mind-control
psychic abilities what I was having
credit was strength and being able to
punch at the speed of lights and if
we're including manga powers too well
freezing abilities I Jess and
shape-shifting into a bloody
Velociraptor oh and I'm sure there was
another power I forgot to mention
oh yeah he can stop time with you I mean
Jesus baby [ __ ] Christ this guy's
just so ridiculously overpowered it's
not even funny
or as Dragon Ball Z likes to put it he's
sorry even when he's just initiating his
powers it is so epic that it's become a
catchphrase for anime geeks all rounds
but then again how couldn't it I mean
you could just about put just about any
context though instantaneously make it
about 100 percent more epic same thing
we do every night pinky try to take over
the lot and that's just one of his many
iconic catchphrases by Kenshiro the
noises he makes during a flurry of
punches has become its own catchphrase
which is not accompanied by his famous
finishing move charging very large
vehicles most notably steam rollers onto
the enemy now let's not forget he has
the ability to kill puppies were still
being awesome and also his final
all-powerful transformation after
sucking the blood of a Jaffa turns him
into wait a second does that kind of
something cool now some of you may not
have even heard of the Oh Brando since
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is and the most
popular and made to say the least but if
you've been hanging around the internet
for long enough then you've probably
seen him reference and not even realized
it since his epicness secures this place
is one of the many internet memes that
have come out from his catchphrases his
catchphrase is a Waldo is a pretty
famous anime mean being reference in
many places such as Team four stars DBZ
at Bridge and amv hell heck amv hell 5
is called dedicated to do [ __ ] sakes I
don't know how much more of a reference
you can get as far as famous fighting
noises well the most notable reference
can be seen in the American show heroes
but if you live in Japan then maybe
you've already seen it courtesy of a
group of Japanese virgins meeting up
together to make what sounds like a
stroll through a demented chicken farm
the prom with the air is that he has
such a short run in the anime that you
can't call it much of a run at all we've
only three episodes of screen time under
its belt it felt like he could have
offered so much more but I guess that's
the problem with the anime being only a
sixth episode OVA but still
unfortunately orders potentials losses
in the end his dominance is short-lived
due to our main hero defeating him very
cheaply by way of instantaneous shown in
action day smacking her power up for as
Dragonball Z let's call it
due to his short run in the anime and
just for being a bit too bizarre huh
see what I did there his stepson on this
slightly but when it comes absolute
dominance and power presents and online
internet memes there's little stand in
the way of do before the entire world is
kneeling at his feet number 10
and more Guinea
cook Aquatica syllables row Noah's are
from one piece just so some
[Music]
dear were you well hold on if I just put
one piece character above can cheer and
do brand oh hell the [ __ ] yeah I did
before those of you about to leave out
of utter disgust for my choices I do
have a reason why he is his highness
this sounds certainly not to do with
some fanboy favoritism or anything like
one piece they can't find out for every
fan of one piece watching because I know
there are a lot of you out there you may
be wondering why I chose him over such
people as the main character who's so
[ __ ] that he actually does a 118
becomes cool one my favorite anime
villains ever and a badass grandpa with
a family so big that in a parody of
rivals number of members on Facebook
well in my opinion Zorro is the closest
thing in one piece to the rule of cool I
was looking for I mean forget to source
toilets or deuce he lords three sources
one in this bloody mouth Zorro or Zola
if you're an idiot and you're watching
the four kids bastardized version of one
piece [ __ ] one piece one piece
one piece is the first shipment of the
straw hat pirate and then second
strongest in the crew he seems to be the
exception in the crew since he's the
only one who's always able to stay
serious and can always keep his cool no
matter how stupid everyone gets and in
the serious situations he sometimes a
more reliable leader than the actual
leader himself he maintained the very
cold persona which goes with his massive
killing intent showing no mercy when it
comes to a fight despite his average
size and being a normal human he has
incredible strength and endurance
training using stupidly heavy weights
and displaying inhuman feet though then
again this is one piece one piece where
there are people who can apparently
correct tidal wave with a [ __ ] bird
but you just have to admire as well it's
become stronger I never give up no
matter how strong the opponent he's
facing in fact he relishes the chance to
face a stronger opponent every time his
dream is to become the best Horseman in
the world which he go when he and his
childhood friend made a promise to blah
blah blah who cares by his past how the
[ __ ] can he fight using his mouth and
moreover how the [ __ ] can he speaks so
clearly we're holding a shaft of a sword
in his mouth her shaft in his mouth I
mean seriously must take some skill to
be able to do that let me give it a try
Oh
the problem with Zara is despite being
one of the coolest characters in the
series one piece isn't the coolest
series to begin with I mean yes it has
its moments but come on when you have
character designed to look like this
this this what a [ __ ] I don't know what
the hell this is this this and what the
fun don't really lend yourself to being
the coolest show but that reason Zara
gets himself involved in many of the
silly slapstick humor that goes on
around and like he's constantly part of
a [ __ ] jackass kit or something and
also he leaves us more coolness points
where having a sense of direction that
borders retardedness actually no that's
a bloody lie well he can't even follow a
straight line correctly it crosses the
line of [ __ ] in her so far that the
line is on the [ __ ] horizon now you
would think that some of these things
would put him down on the list more and
that would be true if he hadn't
displayed one of the coolest and most
badass feasts done by anyone on the list
in one of their toughest battles in the
series thus far the crew fights a deadly
combination of a gigantic zombie the
size of a [ __ ] skyscraper along with
one of the seven warlords of the sea
having forth what seems like a
Dragonball Z fight amount of episodes
getting punched stamped trampled using
up all their strength and sustaining
enough damage between them to go to hell
and back three times over
they finally defeat the opponent and
come out victorious the victory is
short-lived as before any of them can
recover another warlord shows up to in
leash a powerful attack that finishes
the entire crew off almost always other
crew members passed out from damage and
fatigue
Zora is the only one still conscious
although he hardly has the strength to
even move anymore
he uses his chance to beg the warlord
for his captain's life in exchange for
his own willing to throw away all his
dreams and ambitions for the loyalty to
his captain
the warlord agrees to let the crew go on
one condition that Zorro experiences
what head is like before he dies see he
has the power to reject all the damage
and pain that Luffy has gone through in
the previous battle just go with it and
if Zorro half-dead from the battle
before enjoys all of luffy's pain and
damage on top of his fatigue already
then the crew are free to go how much
damage has luffy sustains
knowing that he will almost certainly
die from this ordeal Zorro agrees
without hesitation and enters the bubble
of pain to enjoy Hell itself after
waking up one of the crew members
realizes that Zorro is missing and tries
to find out what if anything remains of
his body from that experience
[Music]
London's New York I subdued :
[Music]
that is why
[Music]